okay hello everyone welcome to another
wolf and language design review part of
our incremental language development
uh series we are looking at supposedly
low hanging projects as in low hanging
fruit that uh have been saved up over
the last decade or so
and we're trying to dispatch
them and decide what to do with them
all right
nested list graph well this is
gosh isn't this exactly why do I have to
go to the Juro ticket here
um isn't this exactly what Brad has been
working on with graph evaluation you
know with the
um uh
directed they cyclic evaluate and things
like this or is this something different
anybody know what this is
so Ian had the the options there Ian had
talked a little bit about the
these things as they apply to trees
these options were assuming know what
you wanted was something that takes
nested lists and produces a graph but
I'm not sure that that's what this was
supposed to be
I think we uh I mean this is lovely but
but I think we are
we're exploring a bunch of this stuff
you know and that's part of what our
whole
uh story of um graph evaluation which we
need to do more on I mean I think
directly basically evaluates not by that
name should become a system function
somehow
um um actually after the Tech conference
we rewrote it in the there's a new
version too at wfr right now is probably
under review
okay
well it's a you know
the concept is similar to tree fold
except it's for graphs right guys
only for directed acyclic graphs
if there's a if there's a loop in the
graph you can't get the foliation and
now the new version too
um it does it's much more ordered and
how it does all the calculation and that
ordering is based on first Computing the
foliation
okay but I mean a loop is x equals X
plus one basically I mean it's the same
story
um
yeah I mean
let's let's not go into that right now
okay I don't think I think there's
nothing here
that is still sort of current and
relevant to us
unless I'm missing something any
comments from people
no I think that makes sense to me
okay generate password
I kind of think we should have this I
think this is useful I think this is
something we've got wfr things for I
don't see any good reason we shouldn't
have a system function yeah I mean I
think what we want to do is like we say
have methods or have schemas for you
know is this a string of ASCII
characters you know the standard sort of
things you'd have for a password
generator on a password keeper or yeah
right but I mean but there's a default
you know generate password open close is
just going to give the current default
and obviously if you ask for a password
sometime that you know you're going to
get a different password each time yeah
and presumably
see random
well that's an interesting question is
this something that is
does block random
you know repeats the password generator
or is the password generator more like
um create uuid which presumably create
new ideas not affected by any seed block
random stuff right
that's my understanding
I mean
I mean I I can't imagine that it would
be crazy if it was yeah
and I think generate password should be
like and probably the the create uid
documentation should probably
affirmatively say that it is not
affected by that I bet it doesn't
okay we should explicitly put something
in here okay yeah we'll pass that along
um
so I mean we have
WR version of generate password let's
look at them let's figure out what to do
okay sense yep
and and I you know it should have
options for things like speakable
passwords and you know pass phrases and
stuff like this yeah include special
characters etc etc yeah yeah right
okay um
okay websync
this is basically wget
I think
[Music]
um
I don't know if we have wfrs for this
and I have a feeling it's kind of a
messy business
I mean other words
what would we do you know so so we can
no we can make a directory
that is a copy of some file you know
some some stuff on the web right mm-hmm
I don't know how I mean
does w get like a standard Unix utility
at this point
pretty much I don't know if it if it's
part of all the distributions but it's
pretty ubiquitous
so if I say
that's not encouraging
up it finally came up
okay
I have a question I mean is there a
version of wget that is a an API version
that wget you know five or some things
that are one there but we could just
librar link to
I
not really I mean
right we have curl link and that gives
us access to you know the curl Library
which is
you know has a great deal of overlap
with doubly world
well but do people think this is useful
I mean
you know a scenario that I can imagine
is the local cash mechanism
which is used to Cache a single web page
I can imagine it being pretty nice to be
able to just say I want to Cache this
whole website
so that I can access it locally
I don't know if that makes any sense I
mean so so that I can then use
local file colon stuff
that's what I'm saying
yeah you basically clone some subset of
the
the web tree yeah but I don't know if
this is realistic anymore because I'm
not sure that people are just running
off pure web servers because you can
clone the HTML files and yeah dancing
you know server thing
yeah
um
I could certainly ask for him you know
what overlap there is with with curl
here and if what the applications
actually look like these days
fine let's do that I think this is more
of a wfr story yeah that's at least a
good place to start with
okay
color string
yeah so this is something that we
propose adding to wfr rather than having
a system function we do have some notion
of getting the color string via color
entities
you know so if we look at the tax value
for a given color it includes
the okay so if I say fuchsia
if I could spell it
um another color
wow okay
it's already in the function repository
by the way yeah
what is
color to hex is the name of it
okay so the question is should this be a
system function
yes
there's Beyond just the the hex values
there's HTML names Etc
we have that data in the color entities
but although it's not completely trivial
what and because you know if I tweak
this pink slightly is it still well you
know this makes sense but if we say
what's the name of the color
that's a different story don't we have
don't we have a color name function
[Music]
don't believe so we have two entity of
colors and that may just come back as a
a wolf from language color okay so if I
say
oh yeah let me get the color Chooser up
Okay so
nope not very useful
yeah
um I thought we had a function that said
what the name of the nearest color was I
mean and we also have things like in
Wolf malpha we certainly have things
that tell you the nearest paint colors
and things like this
there's a wfr submission nearest color
name
okay maybe that's what you're thinking
of
that thing okay
okay
so the question is is this useful enough
to be a system function hmm
I mean I don't think that this is what
that proposed function is right color
string
right I mean you can ask for the like I
mean right HTML defines certain standard
color names of
you know yeah I understand
um
right in addition to accepting RGB and
right those are those are specific right
those are very specific colors so
dysfunction is something that takes you
know takes a directive and you know
gives you the name in the specified
format no I understand that but if I've
got an arbitrary RGB color how does html
give a name to that other as opposed to
just a hex value
uh or doesn't it gives it a hex value
okay fine
right but there are also color names
yes
um
okay
well who would be the user who would be
the potential users of this
I I think we should ask
like Jeremy and shoddy
about this one before we before we cut
it off Jeremy Davis I assume yeah yeah
yeah
I wondered if there's some way to
interface this with color data but color
data kind of is a different animal yeah
we're not necessarily working on
individual colors and color data they're
and themes so I don't know how this
relates to
the color palette repository maybe it
doesn't I I'm just I'm having a hard
time Imagining the case
well you need the name of a color
other than in some kind of describe this
picture
type situation
like I mean if I say
for example
yeah that's pretty pathetic
I may be much better to be able to say
the name there
um
okay so I mean
look to me both of these cases both the
hex string which is very algorithmic and
the name thing have mild utility I just
don't know if it's above the threshold
okay they both don't seem crazy to me to
have them
um
color string and color name
I mean it would go along with a lot of
other stuff we have that's that type of
thing
okay let's keep going here
region packing data
well to me this is a in modern times
there's a very wfr like thing
um Todd Roland had gotten a long way and
somebody else also got a fair distance
and encoding all of this stuff
and
I mean do we have like like a lot of
these things like Optimal sorting
networks I look those up probably twice
a year and
uh you know we have conveniently a
demonstration that I think I might have
put in there that has those things in it
but it probably should be in a data
repository entry this probably could be
in a data repository entry as well these
optimal packings
is uh optimal packings are those related
at all to our discussion from last week
which many discussions about image
collages
or Graphics collages
mildly I mean this is more like how do
you pack five discs into a disk into a
circle okay so so it doesn't allow that
the objects you would be packing
together have significantly different
shapes
that's correct in this case
um
um
so so what do you call it when you you
know try to pack a bunch of different
things together
not a packing I mean this is this is
kind of a
uh
semi-exact cover or something
yeah right so this is okay so
okay I forgot this is all in more from
alpha so for goodness sake let's expose
this either as a wfr or in the data
repository okay yeah we we've taken one
pass at looking at it in the the code
and Alpha wasn't super portable but uh
how could it not be portable this is
very algorithmic yeah I think it is
algorithmic I think it's just the way
that it was written isn't very easy to
transpose outside of the scanner
framework in Alpha but it's been a while
since I was in a discussion about that
so maybe it's gotten okay this is lovely
I mean this is lovely I would never
guess or even have remembered that wolf
Marvel would do this
I mean
uh
you know pack 44 squares in a circle I
wonder if it'll do that
yeah look at that it's magnificent
yeah I think the image is in particular
a nice reference to
yeah I mean and this could be
something either wtr I don't know how
growing like this is or how much this is
just a table
mm-hmm we should determine that okay
yeah we'll follow up on that then I mean
I think a whole lot of work was put into
this so let's you know leverage that
okay rule space data
you know I have to say I need this with
some frequency and I mean I'd be
perfectly happy to see it in wdr I think
this is a brad production
I mean this would be rule space data of
cellular automata and then you know
yeah my suggestion was to kind of bundle
this with the rule plot stuff too
Well it can't be in the rule plot
function right well no I'm just saying
make like a super project or something
well yes that might be true but look
arguably
hmm
the question is would there one day be a
simple systems repository that contains
you know in other words
if we've got tag systems and lag systems
and this kind of thing and that kind of
thing you know it feels very
repositoryistic
you know what I'm saying I mean it's not
because we're gonna you know there's
there's all kinds of random types of
systems that have been defined
I don't know see the problem is well
even the cellular automata if you you
know some of the cellular automata that
you can get to work and produce outputs
they don't have a description if they
don't have a description via rule plot
you know I they apparently work I can
see them working but I don't know what
they're doing
so having even just for this base case
of cellular automata having a more
metadata would be really helpful to the
users because the codes can get
extremely confusing well you're saying
to be able to take a code 7564 long
number well right actually actually the
codes that I'm talking about are the
ones that are like a mixture of nested
parentheses or brackets and numbers yeah
but right but now in the cellular
automaton function we have this way of
doing that with associations but we have
no converter from
you know we have total problems we have
no converter between
um
the
uh pure rule number and it's you know
totalistic code blah blah blah next
nearest neighbor whatever thing
that's one as soon as converting between
types of specifications you know this is
a case where
you know it's like program translation
right we got a program and there's
different ways to State the same program
there's kind of a minimal version of
that
it's like Boolean minimize or Boolean
convert where you know there's different
ways to State a Boolean function in
terms of this uh primitive or that
primitive
yeah that may be true but actually to
characterize the problem I think it's
just mainly missing metadata
well but but what's the input what's the
output
well we can if if we have a working
function you know potentially you just
map over all possible inputs and get the
outputs but that still might not tell us
the simplest description of the rule or
the simplest description of the rule is
some piece of metadata that we'd like to
have that if we know that metadata
any potential transformation of codes or
rules or whatever we can do
sorry so so what function are you
proposing though
well I I don't know I mean I think
no I think it could be a data thing
where the you know the purpose of a data
entry for some particular rule is just
to give a succinct description of
um what it's expected to do and maybe
there's more than one look I think
um
you know it's like maybe it's like a
rule information thing where you give it
by the way it works as you say
well actually why aren't we just reusing
the information function
well maybe this is wrong
because something like this
you know
for that particular rule we can do that
we could have an information function
thing that will give it in different
formats but that's not solving the
problem of the rule space data problem
which is asking the question what's the
maximum number if if these things say 30
comma 2 comma 3 what's the maximum
number what what's the range of numbers
that I can put here
see what I'm saying
yeah that's a fairly simple function I
know it's simple but I've worked it out
like a thousand times all the the
totalistic things and this and that and
the other two-dimensional symmetric ones
it's much more complicated it takes one
ten minutes to work out every time I go
and look at some old paper I wrote to
find it you know it's just kind of
goofball
yeah so it sounds like then there's two
separate things that need to be dealt
with the first being the making sure
that all the codes are easy to interpret
and then the second being given like
overall data about all the sets
yeah given the look given a description
which could be in this Association form
you know totalistic I don't know what
what they you know the association form
from from cellular automata and given
that
um
you know given one of these things or
something given a thing that says
Dimension range yeah you see this is the
right thing given a thing that says
dimension
you know two
range
three
then we simply shouldn't be able to ask
how many rules are there consistent with
this look why don't we put a wfr thing
in there for right now that just lets
you take an incomplete Association that
doesn't contain the rule numbers
and lets you from this generate
uh
you know just say how many elements
there are on that rule space
does that make sense Brad I think that's
something for you
yeah
okay so and then and then also the rule
converter let's try and put that in wfr
as well
um
okay so I mean we'll have to have names
for conversions like turn this into a
totalistic rule if it is totalistic or
complain if it isn't those kinds of
things yeah well I may for that I may
have to dig into the source code a
little bit because there really are some
codes I've seen I have no idea what they
mean or what they do okay fine different
different issue okay all right that's on
your thing so let's keep going here
please
time series of timing utilization of all
CPUs and involved in a particular
computation what the heck is that
so I think the idea would be you'd get
something like a performance readout for
an evaluation so rather than timing or
memory used you would get a you know
second by second breakdown of
CPU usage so if you look at like your
task manager or something like that on
the system I think this is crazy yeah
yeah I mean you know by default you know
like on Modern Max we don't even write
the OS won't even let us get this
information necessarily so let's throw
this out this is irrelevant well what
about if there was some thing like
absolute timing that if you put in a
really complicated expression it
automatically breaks the time statistics
down into incremental steps
because like well that's not some kind
of profiling but that's different from
this that that's profiling
of different I mean we've already got
that with Echo timing you've already got
some pieces of that
yeah I use Echo timing a lot but in the
particular case I was thinking of is
like let's say that you write a fairly
complicated function and you don't know
where the Slowdown is yeah I understand
but this is not going to solve that I
mean the look the other case would be
you've got a list and you're doing
operations on every element of the list
and you want to I mean again
okay the thing about profiling which is
what you're basically asking for is
something that as we get better abstract
syntax trees we have a better chance to
be able to do that because we can
actually label pieces of source code and
we can say this piece of source code
took this long right now we don't know
what piece of source code some executed
piece of expression evaluation is
that makes sense so I think there's a
thing in six months we will have
something you know when when we've
really got better abstract syntax trees
or concrete syntax trees we're in better
position for this I think
worthwhile thing but not right now
right let's keep going so this section
is a little bit all over the place we
can try grabbing extra people if we need
to or we can Circle back if there's
particular things okay dotted lines for
obscured 3D edges do we have any hope
there
that would be lovely I mean it's part of
you know it's like cross hatching and
things you know crosshatching was a
creature of the of the 19th century so
to speak for for you know technical
diagrams and it's lovely that we can do
that now although I still have yet to
actually use it in production maybe I
used it once so far
but this would be really cool I mean if
I if I draw something like a um
uh sphere behind a cube or something
like that well I was thinking of just a
um uh you know a graphics 3D
of
um
Style
um icosahedron
[Music]
face form none
yeah I mean it would be really cool to
be able to see the obscured lines here
as as that dotted okay that's what
people used to do you know in books 100
years ago
right
because right now there's nothing we can
do I mean other than you know I could
fill in here some very light
yeah I mean that that's what this is
about
right is how do you show the obscured
edges dotted as they would in any in any
ancient book
okay so I don't know who's involved in I
I would have thought in modern times
with all the stuff we're doing but this
might be rather easy that you'd Sue or
somebody like that might know how to do
it
well I don't think anybody in this
meeting knows how to do it
okay so who's taking that is Avery going
to take that to
I I would suggest yutsu and Brett
I can get I can ask them but but my
opinion is if we can do it we should do
it
this is a very nice thing
I mean I don't know that we should do it
automatically no I don't think we should
do it automatically but I think there
should be a way to do it
mm-hmm I mean just like I wonder if
um
um can I do something like um
uh
what am I doing here hat shading
that's not very useful
why didn't that work
s
terrible
why doesn't that that's probably just
rasterized I mean try re-evaluating it
but why didn't this work
where are my parallel lines
PSI
PSI I mean let's we can try this but I
that shouldn't be any different
okay that's a bug guys
plus it doesn't feel very good here
I mean what I'm looking for which we
don't apparently have
is something analogous to
I mean this style form thing Avery I
think that's for you to report as a bug
okay
okay this is what I'm looking for I'm
looking for that kind of cross hatching
on the faces here
you know what I'm saying with the
appropriate perspective and so on okay
that's another separate question why
can't we do that
because this is just a GPU Shader
as opposed to something like this which
is more algorithmic
I mean more sort of top level
algorithmic
well this reminds me of like drafting
diagrams right which no you said they're
not 100 years old like people still use
this sure the dotted lines absolutely
yeah yes no no no there's nothing I'm
just saying that's what was used 100 of
the time for like mathy type stuff back
in the day yeah yeah but I think it's
it's I you know if you're sending
specs to a machine shop I think that's
still yeah they use yeah so okay
different group of people let's make
sure we have those for another time
okay let's keep going
this is a dead story okay
Hardware random numbers for random own
integer Okay so
I suspect that's we don't have the right
people hey you you really should have
pulled in different set of people here
because I mean we we have you know a
dozen different people potentially
talking on different subjects I know so
we should have put told them they're on
call and pulled them in if we need them
because otherwise we can't make progress
on this I mean this particular thing I
could go Yakety Yak about it but really
we need Rob or somebody else who knows
how the library connections work
makes sense okay
I mean that particular thing seems
worthwhile and it's probably an option
to seed random to get this
am I making sense
[Music]
okay look look come on we gotta have the
right people here for this most of these
are not doable here okay symbolic and by
and matrices that's for Roger it's
nothing to do with future arrays
okay
okay
and symbolic matrices are something
we've been discussing for 20 years I
don't know
you know
I don't know the state of that this
question I mean we have we have that to
a certain extent right
right you can declare something to be an
N by n Matrix and I know I hate the way
that works
but yes
anyway does anybody know if we've
scheduled the meeting about um
uh cleaning the design of data structure
let's be a question for Jose
data container or data structure data
structure data structure
data structure was a preliminary design
that involves Tom and Christopher and
several other people but can we please
get that schedule Avery can you maybe
take that and and
get that okay yeah I'll pass that along
okay extension of moon phase
we should be getting more properties
about the moon in the Astro project you
know yeah
I mean do we need to talk about this
right here I don't think we do I think
this could be considered in process
okay this is recurring dates right
yeah yeah it's part of it is you know
trivial things like next instance of a
leap year or some you know date
qualification and then
recurring dates would be the the general
framework where next previous current
instances of them would come from do we
have next state instance
we have next stage previous date and
current date and they can take existing
granularities or day types so you can
say next date of Wednesday and it will
give you next Wednesday but we can't say
next date of leap year because it's not
a granularity or a day type
okay
but so what about what about string
values inside next state
uh yeah so we have string values for any
granularity or
um
the various day types so what else is
being asked for here
the idea would be you know additional
decorations Beyond granularities and day
types where we have either Notions of
special days so I want to know you know
the next time Pi Day comes around or
Easter I also may want to know you know
when well I mean we've corrected a lot
of holidays for us I don't know whether
we've whether those are accessible here
at all they are in Dev mode I believe oh
really
so I mean but if I say something like um
I don't know is there a Grandparents Day
yeah
we just missed it
and except unless we're in South Sudan
which seems to have just prepped their
own
wow funky
okay
but so we have tons of data on this
stuff
which is not currently exposed in the
language
yeah I mean we do have holidays that
that you can't access through entity
value at least internally so if you do
so that does this work I mean if I say
Grandparents Day
I don't believe that spellings are hook
up yeah so this is the current mechanism
which is it will resolve on Alpha and
then it will return the closest instance
of it
but if you do
something like entity of holiday comma
uh yeah his names are gonna be
so by the way by the way by the way uh I
think we maybe should do a um
uh
a look with graphic design at these at
this
uh
disambiguation yeah this ambiguation
blob I think it could be more beautiful
and easier to read
so could we take that over again for you
could you screen cap this yep I got it
okay
um
okay
okay so we have a bunch of these things
uh
yeah so like if you look at a data set
for example of any of those holidays the
well let's let's see does this work I
mean if I say next date
um
currently
okay
so maybe that should work
yeah it could work I mean part of the
problem right now is that some of this
framework for holidays relies on some
representation of either recurring dates
or headless dates so like if you look at
the date for Halloween it will give you
or mathematic a day you know that's date
function for example is blank in that
one but
it was first year 2000 is that did we
really manage to kind of play that but
I'm going to find out what the fact this
is
does this come from our sort of
proclamation thing from who knows I
don't even want to know
some bizarre thing okay anyway but but
okay so the issue is we don't yet have a
um
uh
a way of specifying recurring dates yeah
so recurring slash generic dates are
kind of a prerequisite to extending this
framework and making it fully fleshed
out fine but
generic dates seem like they're I'm both
generic seems like the most obviously
necessary and then recurring comes after
that yeah and then this is probably even
after that but I think having this work
seems harmless
don't you think
or is it easy to do isn't it just a
property of this well I mean right now
the problem is that the property doesn't
expose the underlying function so
you have to go ask Alpha basically yeah
we could do that but it's not great it's
not great seems to me we're not quite
ready for this okay
okay W the virtual machine function is
previewed in wfr except that it isn't
the Bitcoin one it's things like
um it seems like the PDP one
right repository not wfr right no it's
in wfr okay it's also impacted
okay well right fine by the way somebody
would be nice if um
somebody could add to my home page my
internal home page the packet Repository
so I'm not asking people
yeah I have a note of that I'll pass
that along to Kristen
okay thanks
uh all right so where is it here virtual
machine
oh I'm wrong about it being in in um
uh in the functional repository it's
it's here yeah
right but we didn't get
the um uh blockchain virtual machines
I don't know what the hell happened here
just blank maybe they didn't write that
page
maybe it doesn't work
yeah
um this is yeah this isn't really
submission to the popular repository
I've asked the Creator to update it with
the
most recent tools
okay
I mean it's something where this would
be a great
project which we could feed to Rory for
students and things who want to add
virtual machines it's a good good
project
both the abstract ones the blockchain
ones Etc
could could that get communicated please
yep I could pass that to Corey or Rory
sorry
okay
um
okay I don't think there's any further
action here for this
okay this is data container yes that
that's where that goes
HTTP response function I thought we had
this now
oh
yeah I don't I don't think we have
something that specifically is on the
method yeah
we don't have this that that would be a
web Aficionado has to tell us whether
this is a useful thing it seems useful
to me I mean that's that's what a um
oh my gosh what is it called a um
what kind of API people always say a
rest API yeah that's what a rest API
gosh I haven't used that term in so long
because it went out of fashion but
that's what a rest API really is
supposed to do is is support all those
different methods but in fact what
people came to mean by rest API is
pretty much the get and post methods
right
so I don't quite understand I mean in
let's say it's a delete method I mean
does it have the same I have no idea
what these methods have the same
argument structure
you know with question marks and things
in the URLs and so on I think this is a
question for
Ricardo would be the right person to
answer the question does this actually
make sense so let's ask him
okay structured countries structured U.S
state we should have those
I mean I don't understand why we don't
like structured US state is really a
no-brainer
you know WV for West Virginia and so on
um
structured country I would have thought
we could use the Internet codes and so
on
okay yeah yeah
there are there is built-in support for
you know country and U.S state to read
those codes natively but I don't think
there is a specific structured instance
for either of them
seems useful to me
not huge but useful okay yeah we can
what does structured mean in this
context it means that it doesn't require
any nlu
I see
yeah it's conforming to some predefined
syntaxis that has to be like the
official
like we'd accept wi perhaps in any
capitalization but not
uh no not whisk or something right at
cheese land
right
um
yeah so this seems useful but not you
know it's not a hugely high priority but
it seems useful to me
ah temporal logic
yeah which is itself a subset of General
modal logic
um you know we've looked at this a
couple of times in the past but really I
think having a better plan for modal
logic as a whole makes sense before
specifically tackling temporal logic
well I think it's going to be useful I
mean I look
okay not every invention of mathematical
logic turns out to actually be useful or
sensible
I could start listing ones that aren't
okay I don't really know enough about
you know the different branches of model
logic to know I mean have I ever used
modal logic not really
you know is there a
uh
I mean I think there are pieces of model
logic which spurted out in totally
random useless directions
temporal logic
I kind of know there are things we want
to represent which are conveniently
represented in temporal logic I mean
there's also you know a spatial analog
of temporal logic as well right the the
very preliminary bits of conversations
we've had with Roger where he's
interested in in spatial logic are that
we don't want to put the cart before the
horse and spec these things out for
temporal logic and then have to redo
everything for spatial logic I wouldn't
worry about it
I really wouldn't worry about it I think
we should try and do that I think
they're all fairly complicated and I
think they're different issues for all
of them and you know are we doing 3D
special logic are we doing you know it's
going to get very complicated very
quickly
and I think the 1D case of temporal
logic is worth looking at in its own
merits now other kinds of model Logics
like what's the one called where you
have I mean there's all kinds of crazy
stuff with them you know
um
[ __ ] case semantics and um
uh Montgomery whatever they are and all
this kind of stuff I don't know there's
lots of different kinds none of which
you know I don't really know
um
which um
uh
no
what's possible versus what's impossible
and um
[Music]
yeah I don't know I mean okay
okay my question here
I'm looking at um like this Wikipedia
page as well
um
let's look at the stamp of Encyclopedia
of philosophy
all right
those are interesting that's an
interesting table
I mean as we work towards the symbolic
discourse language and we don't have the
right people to discuss that here
these are things that we will definitely
need I mean at least those one those are
really fairly straightforward ones but
they get it gets much crazier
see here's a very basic question
okay putting the Axiom systems for these
Logics into axiomatic Theory would be an
obvious first step
am I making sense
does anybody even have an opinion about
this
I mean I think some of these motor
Logics are cool although I'm not sure
they're super widely used
no but I mean for a symbolic discourse
language we are going to need these
these things so and so believes that
whatever
sure
I mean again look seems to me the first
step
is get their Axiom system because then
we can prove theorems in these Logics I
mean what else we're going to do with
these logics
okay Jose
what do we intend what would we do with
temporal logic
so we try to connect with to things like
expressing cooking recipes and the flow
of
um programs
and things like that 12 what of a
program how something evolves so here we
have branches so this is one of these
things in which we have branches and so
we can express that these branches is
going something needs to happen in these
rights before something else happens in
the other branch
and things like that
so there there are some applications but
I don't think there is anything urgent
that needs these
no I understand I mean maybe it's
another student type project to try and
okay hold on look there's several
different things one is we can do proofs
in modal Logics I suspect that our
theorem prover is strong enough that we
could actually do many simple proofs
here
sorry we would have to find an extension
right so in the same way that we went
from equational logic to General
predicate logic this would require just
another extension
please don't have that equational Axiom
systems
um that's not great to me I mean
I consider this some sort of extensions
of a general proposition or logic
no I understand that but I think that
they have equational Axiom systems
and don't they I I don't know I think
that would be a first question too yeah
I mean if they don't then what
algorithms do we have for dealing with
them
I I have to believe that they do
oh boy the fact that I don't know the
answer to this is a very very bad sign
does anybody know the answer here
I mean can't a lot of these be
represented in terms of just first order
logic
one would assume so yes
right so so then you know their equation
relaxings for first order logic right
Axiom systems
yes yes
okay so I found a a site that basically
claims that it has the axioms for basic
model logic axis
oh yeah under quotes a standard book van
Bentham I think I've seen that book
um
yeah I mean this just tells freaking
accident systems
they're just axioms
you know Diamond p
is equivalent to square Diamond p
okay fine I mean we can in fact we've
already got things like this here this
is the same Axiom here
feeling with the same number as the
other thing I'm looking at
so okay first step is if we bring you
know axiomatic Theory I don't know
whether we have anybody who's currently
curating axiomatic Theory
I don't know Jose you you were the last
point of contact there
um no I I don't think anybody is working
on that right now
so Nick has uh
made some changes in
proof object and find equation of proof
and right between the last thing we did
have those been committed are those in
13-2 yes they are in serpenter
okay
well I mean maybe some people at the
Institute want to contribute some some
axiomatic Theory stuff because we've got
a whole bunch of stuff okay this is this
is a
I don't know how we deal with this but
but this seems like it's a repository I
mean it it will be
okay this is a good reason to have a
axiomatic Theory repository so people
can contribute to it
but this seems like you know it seems
like these model logic things are the
kind of thing that would take somebody
who actually is has actually understood
like an hour to put in the basic axioms
here
and I I okay the question is does
anybody know how modal logic works that
is the question and then for temporal
logic
how much had we already implemented Jose
is there enough stuff that we could just
put a packlet out there of what we have
so far of temporal logic
so um
in the previous project what we did is
creating some design for the ideal
operators Etc the extensions here and
then connecting to an external library
that was doing the proofs
and the proofs are believed to be not
the equation is that true or or do we
have any idea well at the time we didn't
have the extension of equational proof
to first order logic that Jonathan
created and so that's why we went
directly to an external library that was
handling this type of logic
but I don't think Jonathan's extension
is terribly efficient it's not that's
why I'm worried of extending it yet
again here
right my understanding is that this is
this is some sort of extension of of the
capabilities of propositional logic and
well I so I think the goal would be you
know can we take including maybe the
external Library connection could we
take that and put it in the Repository
perhaps we could explore that let's find
out
I I consider this to be
I mean I don't know how important this
is that this is one of the pillars that
is going to be necessary for the
symbolic discourse language project
it's one of the calculative representing
the world that's going to be needed
so it'd be great to know
what the status is
all right let's go on for the time being
here
um
Hans comments on the live stream that a
use case for temporologic can be rules
engine and medical informatics for
example timing on taking or
administering drugs
yeah well I bet we you know we've
certainly implemented things like that
because we've had to implement that
particular thing
for that big project
um
that we did a few years ago
um
yeah I mean the representation of see
one question is what's the relationship
between temporal logic and the
representation of recurring dates how
close are they what's through you know
what
because if we're saying
this thing happens forever this thing
happens until this thing happens and so
on
right
yeah I think there is there's some
potential relationship between them you
know we can kind of think of
temporal logic is you know both both
modal logic and also as symbolic
relationships between dates where
recurring dates or generic dates are
either you know symbolic representations
of scheduling or
something along that lines where there I
could see some interplay but the the
General application of temporal logic is
a little more abstract than than
something that's specifically tied to to
given date instances most of the time
right we explored a bit the the relation
with the geometry of intersections of
intervals yeah
sorry what is that yet another formalism
where we where we be
I mean it's more General because you
know a line has ordering in a way that's
that two Dimensions does not
right that's why it might be useful with
dates with temporal logic not with
General special logic yeah yeah we have
like concrete instances of temporal
logic to some degree with date overlap
skew and date within queue which behind
the scenes use a variation on on the
Region's code for Interval arithmetic
okay well so look the the okay we've got
a definite thing here that is we're
going to need to understand for
recurring dates
and
yeah okay I think we move on I mean it's
clearly a live project that
okay collections what is this
I'd summarize these saying that of the
four main combinatorial things we have
three
so two poles permutation subsets and we
are missing this fourth one multi size
which is what why isn't this tuples
these are
ordered objects but they admit
repetition
the unordered objects
I mean four one is not there because one
four is there basically exactly but four
four one is different from forward sorry
sorry one four is different from one one
four for example
yes
well it does seem like a useful thing I
think the word collections is very
obscure for it
I think the name will decide is is more
or less standard
well it should probably be a built-in
function I mean we've got permutations
we've got
two balls we've got these other things I
mean that seems like it's a
seems useful
so I mean it will be multi-sets of ABC
comma two or something
right
yes we should imitate the what the other
functions do more or less
ah
you can say group Theory tools
pactic multi what is group Theory tools
what is that so that that's my internal
functionality to deal with with group
Theory so so we basically already have
this function as well it is a data
structure this is just generating
multi-sets
which seems like the minimal thing it's
like generating you know for
permutations we've both got the function
permutations that generates permutations
and then we've got this symbolic stuff
that you built for dealing with
permutations as permutations which seems
to me a higher level issue
a bunch of multi-set utilities and
functional repository that Bob knackbar
did as well
which take a multi-set object of some
kind
uh no just simplest list of lists
or I think associations maybe too like
what would come out of counts
okay well then that's a good thing to
look at it seems like this is a
worthwhile piece of functionality
um
my gosh
I don't quite understand this
all right look multi-set seem like
they're worth looking at
I mean this is some kind of outer
is it I I don't know what these are
Nick seems like this is your kind of
thing to take a look at
do you agree or
okay
yeah I mean yes most definitely yeah so
I I added um a link to the package I was
talking about
from millions of years ago oh my gosh
this is from
but it has it do you see the flexible
notation it takes in in the list of us
not possibly nice
nice
and it's only a decade old but what the
hell is it doing in the in the library
archive so it's for math source
well it's it's an old package but I I
think I've played with it in the past
and it's quite powerful
let's put let's put it in the in the in
the packet repository to begin with or a
functional positive just one function
um
yeah it deserves more more exposure
certainly
oh it looks really really old how old is
it like 30 years old
um I've done things so much this says
2011.
yes but I don't believe it
why would it be in the library like this
in the
if it was that recent I thought we
hadn't been adding things for 25 years
to this
I I don't know
I'm
my interaction with this doesn't go that
far right
well this looks like a lovely thing I
mean my question would be for people
trying to find things for the password
repository why haven't we looked in the
library if there's things as good as
this there
this looks great I mean let's reach out
to its author see what you know you know
do something about it
um
all right let's keep going here
map Nest list
the heck is this
Brad do you understand this
I've never seen it before
okay could you take a look at it and see
what you can understand what it is I
suspect it's been superseded by
something we're doing with
multi-computation
okay let's have a quick look down some
of these other things
um
this thing here
I would really like to see us have a
function like this D Trend it's
something that I want to do with great
regularity you know you have some random
you know some random thing and you know
it has some I don't know what you know
it's let's say it's a
I don't know let's say we've got
something like this we've got you know
table we've got a random walk of some
kind
I don't know you guys know what I'm
talking about right
effectively what's that High
highlighting outliers by basically
removing you know if we have a a linear
just it's very straightforward I mean it
just there are plenty of cases where
there's some you know fluctuations
around an overall linear increase or
something
so isn't this isn't this already I mean
I think this is called like the the
residuals of the fit or something I
think like linear model fit might have a
way of just asking for the residual ones
probably does but I still think this is
a function that shouldn't require you to
dive all the way into you know linear
model fitting and God knows well but I
think you do have to I mean
like I I I think this function you know
that the user has to be able to say
something like oh my my uh you know my
data is linear or my data is exponential
or whatever a day after you're
responsible for making the you know the
call to the fitting function
perhaps
right maybe the fitting function is just
like moving average or something like
that too
but they've responsible for determining
the radius and stuff like that
right I just think this is something
that's that's not too hard and it has a
very it's a very well-known technical
thing
that well I used to make
but
I just think that that
it's like
you know we've got standard eyes for
example
okay which which just makes things and I
admit I haven't used it very often but
um
out that does this
right but but I mean
one of the differences though is that
there isn't as far as I know there isn't
some other well-known term that means
standardized that we already make
available
well but d-trend
I mean
look linear detrending
is useful and pretty obvious you know
you've given some data
so I think that the term D Trend I think
is like I would have no idea what that
means and I would never assume it's
restricted to being linear you know and
so I you know if the point is we're just
finding up a different
word for like the residuals of the fit
you know but there's already a
well-known word for it and we already
support it under that name I don't
understand what the point is
I think we need the statistics folk here
um all right we should wrap up
uh
right now we've managed to get through a
decent amount of stuff
um next time again if we let's please
have let's order these in such a way
that we can get people in who know about
these particular functions
okay yeah we'll have it collected and
have people uncut and then just just on
on call so that if we get to it we can
bring them in
um
all right sounds good anything else
right now
nope that should do it thanks guys see
you all soon